there are some people who claim that
Hollywood friendships don't last they
usually end up in marriage the next
presenter I'm happy to say is to start
with whom I've maintained a friendship
for many years because he never proposed
to me here is that sturdy cinema citizen
mr. Fred MacMurray
say Bob the how long that we really
don't engine well I remember you from
the old days of paramount you were a
leading man yeah well I remember I
remember you from the older days I've
brought you were a comedian well we all
grow I have the infant Barnabas you were
a sex plane I remember using the pool
you were a cheap if you're good out here
I'll give you the quarterback in a pop
art apart psychedelic world
the special effects men of the movie
studios can do things with film that no
pop up or hop had ever visualized thanks
to the skilled artists who bring life to
the most far-off demands of writers or
directors nothing is impossible
all this needed is time money and the
talents of men such as those nominated
for this year's Oscar in special visual
events special visual effects they are
art Cruikshank for Fantastic Voyage and
Lynn woody
Linwood G done for hava may I have the
envelope please bill thank you general
more nervous in the nominees and the
winner is art Cruikshank for Fantastic
Four
my thanks to the many talented
technicians whose combined efforts made
this picture possible and I also want to
thank the man who should be here beside
me mr. Elbe habit Thank You Academy